hello everybody been in John Luke here
with a hot destron tip for those of you
just starting up the game when you get
to chapter 2 you might be inclined to
want to start doing all the side quests
because the game opens up but we're here
to tell you don't don't don't do it
don't do it do not do it when you are
about to go to chapter 3 bed you get a
notification that kind of implies that
you might not be able to come back
yeah which for you you were like I won't
be able to come back dropped everything
and went right back in and started
delivering all my packages but don't
listen to that sign if you feel like
you're ready to go go for it
the thing is you can always come back to
the chapter 2 area and do any of those
deliveries that you want to do yes and
in fact you actually get some without
spoiling it some equipment that makes
those deliveries much easier to actually
handle you said you spent what like 20
hours yeah that chapter 2 area just
doing everything you saved me the
trouble and because I was gonna do the
same thing it turns out nope I could
just go chapter 3 come back and now I
can do all the side stuff but it's a lot
easier to do but yeah II you should also
actually go back and do that side stuff
definition is worth doing there is a lot
of good if you want to spend those 20
hours like I did doing it then in there
go ahead you could do it but this is
more like a heads up yeah okay you a hot
warning here if you're worried that you
might not be able to come back to the
stuff you might miss out on your boy
Jeff Keely who is in the chapter 2 area
don't worry about it you can always find
him anyway that's our hot advice don't
stick in chapter 2 for too long this is
a Dragon Age Inquisition hinterland
situation don't stay in the hinterlands
don't stay in chapter 2 exact going to
chapter 3 and then come back yeah and do
that hot side stuff and hopefully this 2
minute video will save you 20 hours of
your life if that's not what you want to
do exactly anyway we want to keep it
short and sweet get right to the point
thanks for watching guys if you want
more destron and content we got so many
videos so much so much you can check out
all of that here on youtube or on site
wherever you're watching thanks for
watching